well it feels sometimes like we've lost
our way and it feels sometimes like the
world's gone mad the unintended
consequences of radical progress the
unintended consequences of the
liberation of the human nervous system
by electrifying our thoughts and
distributing them massively through
social media has led to a new kind of
pillaging of our inner life where a
thousand in one algorithms compete for
our attention and when information is
cheap attention becomes expensive what
has happened friends that is driving us
mad is a new kind of illness forged by
the coupling of the human and the
algorithm the unintended consequence is
something Douglas rashkov has called
digr you can feel it every day the
temperature is going off the rails log
into the social media platforms and you
feel immediately invaded and your sense
making is thwarted and you've lost the
way and you've lost your path and the
mental health epidemic is real and the
depression and the suicide and the
anxiety and the OCD and the PTSD and the
ruminations and the excessive
self-consciousness and it's going off
the rails the tribalism it's all
consuming and it's making us implode and
so the fresh new question becomes where
do we go from here how do we find our
way what new kind of perspective is
needed what new kind of visionary
understanding is required what new kind
of reframing might bring us back into
some kind of coherence well I find a lot
of perspective and
clarifying
introspection from getting past
theomorphic perspective sometimes
looking at models of the solar system
watching the planets orbiting the Sun
and then zooming out until I see the
galaxies and I imagine our galaxy is one
of many galaxies hurdling through some
impossibly vast space and before I know
it I recontextualize the self and start
to see myself as a marvelous conduit in
a Timeless hole from which molecules and
meanings flow from neurons to nebula and
Back Again from atoms to Star systems
and back again it's said that there's
more neuronal Connections in their brain
and there are stars in the Milky Way
galaxy there's so much profundity that
goes within so much profundity that goes
without we are suspending Paradox
somewhere between Divinity and mortality
somewhere between infinity and finitude
somewhere that doesn't make sense yet
makes all the sense and this
recontextualization this different kind
of perspective serves to bring me closer
to others it makes me want to hold your
hand it makes me want to say yes we can
it makes me want to be humble for we are
made of Earth but also be Noble for We
Are made of stars there is a psychedelic
ego dissolving Revelation a flash of
insight that at once becomes clear that
we are a way for the cosmos to know
itself and so the crushing fibrillating
anxiousness the corrupted sense making
the digipen thing that has become of The
Human Condition right now puts us at a
precipice of transformation this could
be our greatest moment it could be the
birth of something new this is the birth
canal and it's bloody and we might not
make our way out but if we do the
crysalis will turn into a butterfly add
Astra we go to the Stars next but we've
got to wake up we've got to show up
we've got to come back into Center to
realize that we are cells and atoms and
electrons and SAR systems hurled by no
choice of our own into this impossible
tapestry of sublime Rapture this
suchness this
overwhelm static overwhelm that comes
from smashing our sense of separateness
in quaking annihilating glory and coming
back into a Radiance that simply
says
wow you know at the end of the film
contact when jod Foster Goes Through the
Wormhole and meets the aliens at the end
of time she says my God a Celestial
event they should have sent a poet they
should have sent a
poet wake up
show up so This Is Our
Moment This is Our
Moment